all right i'm just going to interrupt
actually beth because we're going
to downing street and boris johnson who
no doubt will have something to say
too about the football this morning sad
and
rueful but also filled with pride and
hope
and with thanks to gareth southgate and
the whole england squad
for the best campaign by any england
team in any
tournament that i can remember they made
history
they lifted our spirits they brought joy
to this country and i know that they
will continue to do so
and to those who have been directing
racist
abuse at some of the players i said
shame on you and i hope you will crawl
back under the rock
from which you emerged because this
entire team
played like heroes and i'm sure that
this is just
the beginning of their achievements and
i say bring on
qatar next year and let's also
dare to start to hope that together with
ireland
our united kingdom can host the world
cup
in 2013.
turning now to step four of our roadmap
we've come to a stage in the pandemic
when there is no easy answer and no
obvious date for unlocking
we have cases rising significantly with
more than 30 000
per day and we can see what is happening
across europe
as the delta variant takes hold among
our friends
we know we're going to see more
hospitalizations and
more deaths from covid but we also know
that this wave was clearly foreseen by
our scientists
when we first set out that roadmap in
february
and if anything so far we are in the
middle
range of their projections for
infections and at the lower end
of their projections for mortality
and we also know that if we were now to
delay
this fourth step for instance to
september or later
then we would be reopening as the
weather gets colder
and as the virus acquires a greater
natural advantage and when
schools are back and so
we think now is the right moment to
proceed when we have
the natural fire break of the school
holidays in the next few
days and chris and patrick will set out
in just a minute how we are meeting the
four tests
for step four in england
but it is absolutely vital that we
proceed
now with caution and i cannot say this
powerfully or emphatically enough
this pandemic is not over
this disease coronavirus continues to
carry risks for you
and your family we cannot simply revert
instantly from monday the 19th of july
to life as it was before covid
we will stick to our plan to lift legal
restrictions
and to lift social distancing but
we expect and recommend that people wear
a face covering
in crowded and enclosed spaces where you
come into contact with those you don't
normally meet
such as on public transport we're
removing the government instruction to
work from home where you can
but we don't expect that the whole
country will return
to their deaths as one from monday
and we're setting out guidance for
business for a gradual return to work
over the summer and as a matter of
social responsibility
we're urging nightclubs and other venues
with large crowds to make use of the nhs
covid pass
which shows proof of vaccination
vaccination
a recent negative test or natural
immunity
as a means of entry
we're updating our guidance for the
clinically extremely vulnerable
on how they can keep themselves safe and
i generally urge everyone
to keep thinking of others and to
consider the risks
we'll keep our tough border policy
including quarantine
for those arriving from redless
countries and
we will keep the test trace and isolate
system
in place every week that goes by we're
getting hundreds of thousands
more jabs into arms and our delay
to the roadmap that we announced last
month
has enabled us to get seven million more
jabs
in the last four weeks alone
by next monday two-thirds of adults will
have received
a second dose and every adult will have
been offered
a first dose and it is the single
most crucial thing now that you get that
jab a jab that can protect you
and your family and allow you for
instance to go on holiday
and this is of course only thanks to the
vaccine program
that we are able to take these cautious
steps
now but to take these steps
we must be cautious and we must be
vaccinated
so please get that jab